mmm hello and welcome to this twitch
stream a bit of a late start on Saturday
at least on my end but I wanted to do
something about the candidates
tournament
I hope somebody is around I've got
somebody in the chat hello - yeah like
Eli 8 7 8 you're the first round so I
want to cover the candidates a little
bit and I have to say that I haven't
watched or that much about it
simply because today I was quite busy
and I only had the opportunity to like
once in a while have a look at what was
going on so I know the results and I and
I am I only vaguely know how the games
went so I like you know the openings and
so on but I don't know for example how
kramnik won or how mad you are of one
also so um I want to look through the
games and just want to convey my
impressions as I go through them I'm
using the lead chess study here really
nice feature and first of all I'd like
to do it without the engine I will
definitely use the engine at some point
but um I don't want to have it on the
whole time so that we stay at the
evaluation together here that is
something I want to try if however the
situation gets very complicated and I
don't really know what what to make of
it I will use the computer it wouldn't
make any sense to completely yeah
completely ignorant it's it's a good
advice to have so I want to look through
all four games some might take a while
I'm not going to be on for three hours
and I cannot do that but I want to come
a little bit you will have to use the
engine in the
in game it's sick okay yeah the Aronian
game is the draw and it's not a would
actually has some engine evaluation here
in the study okay huh okay
hmm okay I don't really hate it if it's
there yeah but let's let's use it I'm
Emily I just used this here that was
some that was already in here this study
I could have used something else maybe
without without any any evals okay let's
have a look
aronia and ding we start with that
that's that's a draw so we have we have
the Makino's variation in the English
opening this is one of the reasons why I
always like to see 493 this line the
mckenas with eform is some yeah I think
it's objectively quite good and it's
really really a killer on the club level
because people have no clue how to
answer it on the professional level of
course they know how to deal with this
opening so black goes d5 that is the
best move e5 d 4 this is how black
should play that's the best possible way
of playing for black optics takes
yeahi'm
white can also take on g7 but this is
just this is just very boring of this
kind of thing
the some time that that at some point
was played against me when I was black
and really after like here here nothing
much happens
that's very boring the better move is B
takes what aronia played Queen takes
here White has a choice you can play
Knight to f3 or d4 there are some
differences between the two move order
move order nuances but I think d4 is
natural enough so let's do this
and the dingos b6 this is interesting
yeah okay I have not prepared this this
broadcast I just make it up as I go
along
that's something that you could look up
v6 is not the main move they
traditionally go e5 here but I always
felt that white has a slight pool there
not that much but a little bit but this
is what is the traditional main line at
least is a typical way of playing there
is Knight f3 TX and Bishop g5
this is how they often flake we need six
but should be to f6 94 2007 this is what
I remember you bring about the theory
I'm sorry so this is there an
alternative didn't play b6 okay and now
h 4 by Aronian that's a funny funny move
yeah this is the kind of yeah and why is
the makita's a club level killer yeah
the problem is that people often just
have no clue what they want to do
I even had if I've played against me
which is very name or people play this
after you v Quincy flaw you're already
toast now here black has to go back here
with Bishop f8 great stuff or they play
but I also had they play C 5-3598 Knight
f3 knight c6 to take and now after this
white has a great compensation already
but yeah people people play this for
example c5 takes Bishop f4 resigns for
example there there are many many lines
that are terrible for black if they play
a somewhat suboptimal
so we go to the game yeah let's have a
look at the game h4 interesting it's
not something I'm aware of as a move
yeah it's a kind of surprise that is
probably interesting to play white is
probably not going to be worse
and black will maybe yeah have never
prepared that in any detail well so
Bishop g5 is obviously the idea Bishop
d7 played by ding what nice to see the
time spend yeah but anyway there should
be seven that looks like the most
natural move ever Bishop g5 attacking
the Queen and Queen to f5 okay
no he only has g6 and f5 and their five
looks a little bit more logical also
because the babies get this same so
thanks for subscribing that Bishop is a
beast okay
the Queen now has Queen a5 bailable and
this is what happens next after Queen g6
you don't have that available I'm so
understandable decision Bishop d3 that
was certainly something that Aronian had
prepared and expected and now okay this
is hanging and the pawn is saying so you
have to you cannot cover it both and he
goes King to everyone talking
that's crazy stuff
96 okay it looks like normal developing
move here what the engine earlier here
Auto commentators here was inaccuracy
best move was Bishop d6 me what to do
with this information
first of all I'd like to like to see
just just to just out of curiosity why
exactly that could not be taken I mean
it looks very risky and it's not an
important pawn to take but I just want
to want to check it briefly is it just
night it's warm
is there something even more of an issue
that's true where you cannot see the
computer assessment from black I mean if
it is there might work might as well
display it how do I actually change that
in the stream
[Music]
it's not part of it yeah yeah I'm sorry
sorry yeah I'm from Germany but I'm not
from b2 felt you don't have anything to
say against be the felt but I'm not from
them mm I simply don't have this I can
actually you know what I can do I can
reduce the zoom level a little bit and
you see that and you see the eval but I
should probably you know if I if I do
this CAPTCHA probably should should do
this a new but I don't really know how
okay it has everything that there is
just a second there please so this
it looks kind of weird yeah I mean if it
is there I might as well display it but
it's also the left hand side doesn't
really help you know I might as well
make the whole thing a little bit bigger
I know my face is there ah what am I
doing here like this that also looks bad
I should have just kept it as it was
yeah okay that's great
that better I don't know I think it's
okay
what can I actually I can actually you
know what I can do I can get rid of that
and make it a little bit bigger that's
probably the best I can do now I think
it's okay yeah but I can put over here
yeah and now I think I think it's okay
let's do it let's do it from here um
yeah no I know it's know for me the
screen is a bit smaller anyway let's
have a look so we might definitely ask
compensation with night eat or something
like that the poor on c3 is not really
that important but I don't think there's
something particularly dangerous that
days
there's no direct refutation I mean this
is an important point
c3 it's not an important pawn so I think
sensible developing move makes sense
Bishop d6 knight c6 makes sense so
knight c6 rook b1 yeah this is now a
little bit under pressure
black goes f6 f6 okay black cannot
castle yeah that is a problem
they cannot castle long so I I guess I
am I get it yeah f6
no I'm not going to play a tournament on
one o'clock
definitely not I'm trying to cover the
candidates see a little bit so Bishop d2
castles long I have to play tournament
game tomorrow and I shouldn't do this in
the first place but I wanted so castles
long and a4 okay Jeff you asked me and
that must be a good position of a white
the King on f1 isn't the problem
and somehow blacks Queen looks in in
danger so II five and c5 Wow
see five interesting I would have
thought that something normal-ish no
that's not a theoretical position I
think h4 already is quite weird it says
something bad about my t2 here on yeah
Christine understand I read what you
said but we're not at the final position
yet so ok 92 I just wonder if he would
see five is a drastic move and I
understand he wants to get to get the
Queen down yeah you can try that but
I can try this yeah but here
you know you're not threatening to move
the rook because the bishop is not
protected at all yeah you're not
threatening rook b6 or any rook move s
d3 Hanks was Czech
so this is a little bit too maybe a bit
too direct but you can probably develop
you know that I don't see I don't see a
direct issue with that yeah this is
interesting though I mean if you look at
this now black can play this and it's
certainly an option at 92 I don't think
that's something particularly wrong
about it
are you 8 c5 ok and black snatched that
if I was a sharp movie I mean black
tries to do something in the center but
let's check the c5 this this so now
okay I see Rukh age three covering the
bishop so this is actually now
threatening to move the rook black took
on d4 okay okay so even the draw yeah
was a wasn't completely completely
bonkers game
[Music]
ha I don't I don't get it what Bishop b2
was played okay I cannot move this rook
hmm Wow I tried to do that without the
engine until it's a really tall order
and so I mean if I do this yeah just for
fun
the Queen has no move you know move at
all but if I take there's a check so I
can simply capture here right this this
and blackest black is probably killing
him company that that is a disaster him
okay that's terrible
lookee five looks looks bad anyway but
still and I could also somewhere else
and then take on d4 I mean the Queen
only has a five minimum what the heck q
yeah the Queen cannot just take the
bishop here there's a root on h3 that's
really really weird I know but I would
be curious to know what happens here
exactly if I take the take the piece
what is black doing they'll just nice
form
oh my god I would use Lucette game with
both colors easily I mean very easily
I mean I absolutely believe that blacks
should be okay and it's like like my
intuition tells me it should be but this
is just crazy completely crazy so what
did what did Lee won't do it should be
true Wow okay I mean I see the point yet
here it is completely safe and and this
is the threat Oh idea let's say I'm not
sure very threatening so what did thing
do look t6 that is not how can you come
up with that move like just like why is
that even a candidate what does rocket
is 16
well I'm not quite sure what he should
play though I mean white is threatening
to move it and the best move was Bishop
a8 according to the engine for Queen
Queen b7 don't forget about it nobody
plays that
okay so rook d6 was played and now we
know that the engine didn't like that
and held rook b2 is stronger than rupee
one in the game that was locked p1 and
they made a draw here okay and we know
that the engine said rook b2 is stronger
I mean first of all in the actual game
if I take it yeah what what's going on
there then like 25 or something or what
what is happening I mean has to be the
the queen has no other move
they have no clue what's going on you
said bad for white I mean it's possible
black already has a bunch of pawns and
of course that line up on the long
diagonal here is very very problematic
one difference between rock here and
Ruby mana is definitely that this is
covered so in the yeah yeah you're right
here clash key this is the line that the
engine is showing here you can actually
take yes this is covered so here F takes
sorry F takes and Queen to b3 and it
seems that the engine gives white a
substantial advantage VM it's possible I
mean just just in terms of material
white is ahead and if there isn't
anything special going on it it must be
fine
yeah it's an extremely weird position so
I kind of understand that the engine
could give an advantage there but it's
really tough be one instead yeah and
then they made this drawn yeah it's
possible that here aronia didn't really
have a choice yeah that's really
possible I mean for example here if you
take I think a knight takes is the
problem threatening on g2 and on d2 and
you cannot you cannot cover it cover it
at the same time and if you cannot take
only five what exactly are you playing
nothing really great nothing great
that that's obvious him no I understand
why why they made a draw here I mean
black after rook b5 and I cannot cannot
avoid it anyway a black has to make the
draw the Queen has no squares I know I
don't think this is hard to see that
rook that this is a difference
I think that's easy to see that this is
covered the problem is that it's so
difficult to evaluate and come up come
up to a conclusion that this would be
would be fine for why this is the thing
you see em I'm I'll be in Berlin
starting Friday and I'm doing four
rounds of live commentary in German at
the side yeah it's possible I mean this
is just difficult to evaluate maybe even
he came up to this point I mean this is
the engine law in him and something
irritated him which is very
understandable it's just a very lucky
position Black has two pawns I mean this
is not enough like on paper but it's
easy to imagine that there's a third
pawn
somehow taken and then think some things
slide up okay I mean there are three
decisive games and I feel they are oh I
heard they were long so we should look
at those baby but is well that was a
crazy game an interesting game
so um any say any preference for what
game to check next any preference yeah
this is tough to analyze yeah because
it's purely tactical I mean you if you
if you analyze that like here and this
some in the setting I would really need
more time yeah because I mean those guys
are much better players than I am and if
I want to do it without the engine it's
it's tough via so anything anything
kayaking last okay Caruana Fabiano okay
let's go karana
this was I think it was a Catalan yeah I
saw that it was a Catalan and that is
all I know that I knew okay so so so I
like to say so anyway and with wesayso
playing it will probably get over killed
okay so chick and like ghost e-file yeah
just one thing this check on before and
then going back to e7 that's very
commonly seen in the in the Catalan and
I think many people don't quite get what
this actually accomplishes the the
Bishop is on the tool and to understand
what this check makes sense it is
advisable to look at the position a
couple of months later so especially or
in particular here black now does not
take on c4 but places six to support a
center he's playing a closed centre
structure not taking on c4 and here
white has the move Bishop d2 extra yeah
Bishop before check and back so white
was gifted this move we should actually
look at the same position without the
check to understand what the difference
is so this would be this position here
for example white can play Queen c2 or
92 and I'm starting with 92 to show the
point that is of course not possible
with the bishop sitting on that Square
after 90 to 97 Quincy to be 6e for white
is getting C form e form in quite
quickly and the bishop oftentimes later
will be nicely positioned on b2 so for
example there should be to be three rook
c8 you should be to see five takes takes
this variation is is a theoretical line
um can I get the same with the bishop on
a6 and so on but I just want to show the
bishop is here ideally placed and the
knight is on D to supporting the pawn so
D takes Knight c4 is possible
and in our position right now obviously
has doesn't have night BT B - D - he can
try something else
of course but how are you going to ever
get to this kind of position again where
we have the bishop on the long diagonal
and the night somewhere you could try to
somehow regroup this with Bishop C 392
but the issue is are you playing this
now really black might take this all of
a sudden and then oh silly look silly
and whatever why does it is a little bit
of it's a little bit of a hassle to
correct us the bishop is actually not
well placed on the tool and that is the
reason why white players normally switch
to an entirely different play there you
have a hard time to get if Orion is the
problem and oftentimes they play Bishop
f4 you know and in the game that
happened you can even play Bishop f4
here and after Knight h5 drop it back to
c1 and then Knight to f6
this has had this has happened yeah as
folks here said yeah this is something
that has happened in games in them in
the game here Queen to b3 is played
covering the pawn Knight bt7
I know Bishop f4 air White has to
somehow move this again it's really not
good on D - so f4 is a good square yeah
here black has a couple of ideas
available this a5 that is what what
soleplate black can also play in a more
that's a natural way with b6 for example
something like this b6 and now white can
also play look to see one that the F
rook now can't go directly to c1 and
white has a gay white tries to play with
the pieces here and potentially take on
d5 so for example B should be 7 and then
the capture is possible there are some
interesting interesting points there
already am here the bishop and rook on
c7 so black has to see if his
able to take this effect yeah this is
not clear to me and at this particular
moment if this is an issue rook c7 looks
a little bit annoying at least maybe
Bishop a6 as possible that's true
there's a remark why not Knight h5 there
yes definitely possible near for example
after here black could Co Knight h5
immediately that's possible one after b6
you can still play Knight h5 harassing
this Bishop so there are a couple of
options the move f5 looks a bit
mysterious but it can sometimes attack
the Queen where the tempo and it can
prepare the move b5 yeah and I only
looked at the Drude Aronian game and
that can prepare the move b5 and we will
see in the game that this happens so
rook to e1 that makes sense
yellow to chess guy four four four nine
h5 yeah black is kicking this bishop see
one okay yeah it looks a bit odd here
but we have seen that the bishop is not
does not have a clear clearly preferable
square that say you can't sometimes put
it here but I think against this kind of
idea often times f5 is played and you
have to be worried about this sometimes
not usually worried but okay Bishop c1
and black just drops back now that's
really I was funny other day they go h5
going back and then going back to f6 but
yeah why does sort of it's not clear
what white will do here
so we try tonight BT to probably
preparing Quincy 24 after all yeah
and now b5 and here we see why a 5 is
has a point
yeah if white now decides to snatch this
there is Bishop a6 that's only possible
with the pawn
five not with the porn on a seven this
in fact looks pretty terrible here
because white has just given up e 2
which is not what we want
e 2 is much better pawn than B 5 so no
good and in fact the capture already
looks wrong in this position the knight
on D 2 looks weird the only thing that
it could do from here would be trying to
get to c5 but black here is much quicker
with Bishop a6 before and so on yeah
black is already probably better so c5
played back Caruana this is the normal
reaction to those b5 ideas to grab the
space then think that c5 often invites
is black playing a5 and this is I think
when I see what happened in the game is
that that happen ke5 was played an
important thing is that if black does
absolutely nothing I mean like nothing
why do will go Queen c2 and f4 so we can
I just want to show what happens if
black plays plays nonsense yam to give
this this and whatever and I'm just
making some moves then e 4 is going to
be better it's important to see that if
this happens this kind of trade at first
you might think Oh black gets this great
square on e5 for the night
this is true the knight is nicely placed
on d5 but there is still huge problems
there because white also has squares
namely form it's an excellent square
that black cannot fight for it all I
mean you cannot go out 5 never yeah I
mean he it would blunder is 6 but it's
also strategically terrible so you get
evil and oftentimes e5 as well as white
because again f6 cannot play that so why
does having much better of it
this looks pretty but white has clearly
the better game here
note that this is of course a terrible
piece black has to be more active and I
think that's what he did he played
before and
a for trying to harass white I think now
if one was not played yet if you form
okay it's b3 even on
I mean b3 would be technically possible
yeah it's it's a move to check yeah you
cannot take it as this is a double
attack on both that's ugly
yeah Bishop to c1 either they're
undeveloped in this in this particular
case it makes sense to put it there yeah
I hear you can take with a knight yeah
you can check with a knight but black is
happy to win this him have to be three
this is probably necessary and I'm not
sure what this designs what what this
means here this position yeah looks a
bit strange
I mean this is more active anyway for
black yeah so monkey one was played
simply preparing this and now black is
striking first with you five interesting
yeah okay that's that's an active choice
and the night was taking it I came if
you take with the pawn very tactical now
him black is trying to solve his
problems by technical means so Knight
takes e5 let's have a look at this
Knight takes Knight takes pawn takes I
think this looks a little bit more
logical anywhere to take with the knight
on f3 because now you're actually
allowed to play this quickly and the
bishop c1 comes out again so there is
some logic m92 d7 yeah I mean you can
take a sari
you can look at this you can definitely
look at this the question could be like
if if they do this and with black what
you're doing now the knight on the 2s no
real has nothing nowhere to go I mean
for example this this could be an issue
like if you do any of those Bishop a six
mmm yeah I'm not sure it's it's very
very tough to to evaluate and quickly
like I'm trying to do it now but this
and it makes a more logical impression
to me it's more fluent let's say the
pieces are more fluent and takes takes
in ninety or three so this comes out and
we are a little bit better mobilized
here Bishop takes e5
came yeah that's that's Knight g5 him
yeah and he played 95 this is a problem
but if you like if he does that I think
this looks also a bit questionable him
Bishop III at first looks like a problem
well attacking this and c6 is also under
pressure and also doesn't look right
so Bishop was the choice and 95 always
feels good to threaten meet in one
somehow
so g6 and this is a weakness that's
really a weakness that night now is a
nuisance it has enormous nuisance value
value because h6 is a real weakening and
like f6 96 I mean not now it would be
just a pad same but this idea is always
in the position I feel that this is a
little bit that that's already been
awkward for black yeah or what do you
think what is the opinion of the chat I
would assume that black is already a
little bit a little bit awkward stage
here I have no clue what the engine says
there there is no we don't have it
turned on but what do you say I just
decided that at some points I'm going to
ask the engine and just compare what to
what we think I would assume for a human
player that this makes it's a little bit
if you yeah the the the kingside looks a
bit weak
I would I would assume that why does a
bit barium I think
[Music]
hmm chess God says Black has a strategic
pawn structure advantage I don't see
that where is the pawn structure
advantage the double pawn I don't think
so
you know I would assume that why does a
bit better here let's just switch it on
for a moment and see what happens the
engine gives white I mean this is just a
very very quick evaluation the engine
gives white small advantage yeah it's
not a real it's not a huge depth just a
small advantage yeah this is probably
what it is yeah I mean the engine
defends everything perfectly or as close
to what we think is perfect so what
looks scary sometimes to us is not so
scary for the computer so Bishop f4 that
looks very natural and black goes Queen
b6 for counterplay against the pollen F
tool no no II four looks normal to me
white looks better him I mean and I mean
okay I'm a natural optimist but if I
would have that in a game I would be
very optimistic about my chances simply
I have more I have more pieces near the
king that's really a point for example
in my queen can switch over something
like that I feel is happening and the
game Queen e2 here so the Queen can go
over and then black has tons of pieces
there on the Queen side and and
especially each four is problematic
black can never take this pawn like here
this this Knight takes and that's awful
and we are threatening to take and
blacks King position feels undefended I
think that doesn't look good so okay b3
is was played by Wesley so take take
Queen e2 and to Bishop a6m really Bishop
a6 to c4
Wow
okay I'm going out on a limb fiance
Bishop is 64
after that White has a clear advantage I
will let's let's just do that
yeah 1.1 there I mean come on that
cannot be right
putting the the bishop on that that that
that is of just a bad square I mean I
see that the bishop on say aid wasn't
brilliant but at least it looked like it
defended something and maybe we have a
hard time to play this you cannot take
it for white is threatening to take on
d5 so what are you doing there
so interesting and so what I think is
Bishop 864 isn't good and the computer
basically says yes this evaluation is
correct or the position after that is
good for white so what did black do
wrong if this position like it according
to the engine was still okay maybe Queen
b6 and and B 3 isn't really doing all
that much
for you can player this feels awkward
the black position feels awkward to me
so really really tough - same here I
think the issue is simply that white has
if you check this an important thing -
sometimes to look at is look at the
different areas of the board on the
King's idea if we check like just look
at this box here we have as white we
have every single piece there the only
exception is the rook and this is now
traded so maybe let's do this here on
the King side we have everything
absolutely everything of peace is there
and somehow participating in the attack
on blacks King and blacks pieces all on
the Queen side that cannot be right that
must be a bad position for black it must
be a bad position so somewhere around
here probably black black made a mistake
sorry
I talk too much today some somewhere
around here must be the issue and of
course what I just stated yeah that this
is extremely dangerous is super obvious
for the player of the of their strength
then the thing is sometimes you drift
into this and you see I came home that
is also bad what am I going to do I need
some kind of counter play and then you
start to shift things to the other side
of the board and then you get checkmated
all of a sudden yeah but if you just sit
there passively it's also no good
probably somewhere around here
yeah Queen b6 this makes some sense yeah
definitely protect c6 but it removes the
Queen from the defense this is this is
important potentially important so let
me just if you want to cover here yeah
what about Queen to e7 for example is
animals
I would suggest before as well yeah
black strongest side is the Queen side
isn't he supposed to play there this is
not entirely wrong the problem is if
you're winning on the Queen side and
your chick made it you know what counts
yeah so it has to be a balance you want
some play but if you have all the play
all the pieces on that side of the board
it's very difficult to play this with
black I mean I would instinctively
prefer Queen to e7 and keep the Queen
near of the King but what does the
computer same just just curious the
engine gives Queen b6 it also b3 and
rook a5 look f5 is a move that no human
player will play you can forget about
that this queen is having a bad move my
suggestion if for D 46 oh yeah okay yeah
yeah that is bad okay I didn't see that
one yeah this is the problem this is an
absolute problem
very nice computer line and now blacks
pieces are completely completely
misplaced that that's terrible
very terrible
yeah that was suggested in that shed
good call
very nice that that looks very dangerous
so Queenie seven wasn't great
okay Queen to b6 and what is the end in
saying it b3 I mean that is the the
quick avail of the computer is still
somewhat okay but I mean you know depth
xx it's like nothing him it's really
like nothing and it's possible that the
computer is not really a deep enough to
see how dangerous whites attackers and
now it already gives what is a
substantial edge you know what I'm I'm
calling it I think black it's just verse
here Queen b6 I mean you can do whatever
you want
you're just worse in this position
because yeah you know think of alpha 0
we have all those attacking games it's
it's probably better for white and the
engine just takes time to get this
evaluation straight sometimes it is like
that at least from a practical point of
view this position loops looks bad
really bad and he's six yeah that is the
moment where you you know if you're not
doing something stupid you're winning
you're crashing through now and what is
blacks supposed to do here you take on
he took on e4 takes takes Knight takes
yeah very nice very nice
well bishop give 496 Wow
yeah simply threatening to take him and
it doesn't have squares to go to where
if you go Bishop here for example this
is probably strong enough yeah it's it
should be enough so I just wanted to
check how this ended so 96% e5 Queen e2
and now you're threatening to take and
play Queen e6 that is probably
impossible to fend off Queen f3
attending here and through end resigns
no no you're not surviving this here at
Queen f7 so it's there what's that some
kind of defense still yeah maybe maybe
around here I am there was something
better but I think in a practical game
wow that was bad so somehow black
drifted into this disposition tough to
say really where God got downhill
I mean I have to say that I'm not a huge
fan of those setups for black in general
I tried to make this work for me with
black but I couldn't quite couldn't
quite manage so certainly there was some
sort of improvement year round move 20
or so but who very very tough to play
and I think it's very understandable in
a way understandable lost yeah sometimes
you really don't know what what was
going on there but I think here black
drifted into that coding and getting
into some trouble now it was difficult
certainly yeah the Cromley came next
maybe I only saw in the chrome deck game
that Vladimir was playing some really
offbeat opening yeah this I saw that
this happened that's a funny movie that
doesn't look like it should
refute the Grune felt funny yeah I know
what he wants to do I mean I can tell
you what he wants to do if black is
doing something like something slowest
yeah this this this maybe maybe he's
trying this East Indian defense that's
funny right what is that
East Indian defense maybe he wants to
get something like this on the board
yeah there is an interesting set up that
I've played quite a bit like here maybe
you transpose into some some sort of
green felt yeah yeah bb3
I mean it's it's it's possible it's
possible certainly to play
I have often times actually recommended
to players who wanted an on theoretical
game I have recommended this month quite
a bit and this is not too bad actually
the idea is to play a form and if black
wants to defend against that by direct
means like d5 white can yeah and yeah
what can play this yeah everybody's
shocked now this is actually quite good
and quite playable for white yeah not
not so bad
this prevents e5 and what tries to
expand on the queenside this is actually
I think very reasonable for white okay
b3 played by kramnik and c5 played by
Grisham this is um this is also a
response that you see against III on IBD
to and after the capture this is reached
yeah and now grief shock is doing
exactly what I would do myself and in
fact have done in a game he is playing a
hedgehog
yeah with with g6 and with b6 one thing
is interesting here white has not played
the queenside expansion with a3 and
before the game that I had on the board
a couple of years ago had the pawns on a
3 and B form and in this game that I
played I knew what to do because I had
an idea what to attack with the pawn on
b4 c4 is unprotected I mean it is
protected by many pieces but not by a
pawn anymore
and therefore my idea was to simply
trade of everything yeah this is an
interesting thing maybe to look at I'm
just going to show you something here
I'm going to show you what happens if
black right place with before not that
this is terrible I'm not saying it is
but here I can just show you an idea
that I had played in this game back then
my idea back then was if I trade off
simply all the minor pieces have just
just to show now there's a weakness that
I can attack if all the Knights are gone
I mean I know that makes no sense move I
just want to show you the the general
general idea like here how do you know
it how do we trade I don't want to trade
on e5 maybe I'm confusing you but I
think I'm getting the point across in
such a situation here at the end of the
day you can triple against this and you
can leave it with b5 and d5 so you know
you have to trade up all the minor
pieces and at the end yeah you can do
that but in the Kramnik game
what does not have a three and before
plate he has this healthy structure and
as before it looks more active but it
actually we can see forward a little bit
not that white cannot prevent that yeah
you're not going to lose there by force
but it is an idea that is now out of the
picture with white having this chain of
ponds and the knight on the two fields
bran and kramnik is actually miss
replacing it quickly or regrouping it
quickly still this looks like absolutely
zilch chef it's probably just equal yeah
it must be equal must be an equal
position
[Music]
so Grisha plays completely normal yeah
rook c8 Queen b8 connecting rooks
potentially doubling on the C file yeah
Black has b5 and d5 that are black
spawned leavers and this is actually um
what I'm not sure about you with White's
position White has no porn lever in this
position he has no way to change the
pawn structure what white can do and
probably will do is try to get Knight to
d5 that it's the only real plan and also
the reason why the night now hope to be
one c3 yeah we have Benjamin Feingold in
the chat and he says terrible yes so
what exactly is terrible tell tell us
okay so again white white maybe he can
try to put a knight on to d5 but it's
also not really easy to do and we would
rather have a bishop on g2 and so on so
that is a maneuvering kind of game yeah
and let's see what black does Queen a1
interesting trying to make some pressure
here black goes a 695 now not possible
here because the rook is unprotected on
c2 he moves it yeah maybe now 95 is a
little bit more likely to happen but
black is still I'm able to probably just
trade it he plays rook f8 yeah that
makes sense yeah now 95 would be without
a threat yeah if you you play 95 for
example here there's simply no threat
going on no I'm not sure that black
should take this on d5 probably
shouldn't gem looks a little bit scary
to take now more than scary yeah
black should not take
No and the week light squares make a
sorry impression it doesn't look good
but it is not necessary
yeah after 95 black can simply staying
there's no need to take out anything so
rook ft-1 bishop I hate just staying
basically and now 95 so Kramnik is
really going for that regrouping with
Knight f3 f4 d5 okay rook c5 Knight H 3
and B 5 yeah if you can get that in it's
often a good idea getting that porn
either in Knight f4 metaphorce played
okay
yeah it's interesting it's an
interesting position it's not it's not
lame or anything
now it has 95 ideas and now black takes
on c4 okay activating this bishop i
droped g5 funny hey Brooke swings on the
5th rank of what rank always cool so
black is on that g2 porn but white is
blocking the diagonal with night CD 5 ok
now Knight e5 was played the computer we
still have we already have the computer
eval there the engine wants to take on
d5 I am probably like Knight takes
Bishop g7 and then I have 400 years
instead Knight e5 was played so if black
takes how does that continue them
I mean I think this this looks weird you
know with g2 that looks wrong and white
can probably just take yeah I'm going to
Berlin next Friday and I'm going to do
commentary at the site for a couple of
rounds so yeah that looks like nothing
special
okay Knight e5 was played and white just
dropped back to E - okay it would be
nice to see the time spent yeah it's
it's it's absolutely easily possible
that Grisha already was in time trouble
I mean there was a completely non
theoretical opening and this is of
course always tempting to do against
grease shock yeah he's simply burning
time and just in some cases you really
don't know what what for I mean he's
certainly thinking about something and
I'm not saying he isn't but it sometimes
feels like a huge am a huge let's say a
gamble here to invest that much time and
they're not getting so much out of it so
night before was played
[Music]
and each for Wow and that Lucas is in
trouble let's just say five him and now
II for best smooth was G for according
to the engine chief we're certainly
moved that crumbling thought about
it looks good yeah g4 looks good
I mean okay like has to check yeah
there's simply nothing else politics I'm
just looking at the engine line and I
wonder what kramnik disliked here yeah
you know it looks a little bit open but
black has simply no attacking pieces
they don't wear this absolutely there's
absolutely nothing that black has him
the king is not unsafe just isn't famous
last words
yeah it could be around here by by the
way but because he in 97 is not the most
natural move ever maybe around here
there was the issue but even if you just
dropped this back to e3 instead bad hey
there Queen to be several yeah this is a
problem yeah but this is this issue here
the debts issue this works
probably just just about
no it is this and that good very good
for white the engine line I had looks
pretty awful
it looks pretty awful oh yeah I see I
can see why my g4s is probably better
but it also indeed a very tough decision
if you don't get ninety seven to work
here I mean this is not really nice yes
okay 97 and this probably is a lot
better okay in the game efore misplayed
which also netted the exchange like
blacks pieces are active yeah they have
the two fianchettoed Bishop and the
centralized nodes
I mean why it is certainly better but
it's it's tough
Knight c5 it's a temple and the Queen
and all night is three I mean white must
be better due to the material it just it
just what it is because when black is
active but it's not enough it cannot be
enough compensation f5 oh wow a chronic
just returned to exchange here
who hmm that's interesting
I mean white is better after your Jones
exchange but I'm just wondering if it
was necessary or if you just felt like
it's it's a good transformation that is
not clear to me thank you
for example is instead a threat or
something where you that you have to
react to is there a concrete idea that
black has maybe you just felt that is a
good decision and I mean if we check
this this is forced and here there are
some issues there for example you have
this idea to take and go 94 h6
ideas like that and simply white is
better centralize them and a5 is rather
weak and it adds up it adds up I
understand that white is better in the
engine yeah gives give something nice
for white as soon as well
yeah yeah I think kremlings Russian
Elias said this is just a weak pawn and
that is probably enough for probably
enough for a substantial edge so black
has taken should be six group B 1 as the
necro yeah but if you have no time on
the clock
how do you play this accurately Knight
is six is given us better and then look
a8 that probably just keeps the porneia
but it isn't this is an endgame position
that it's just not easy for blanking on
it's just awkward to play and you have a
fee in Cairo tonight yeah that's usually
not something to avoid okay rook could
be a truck C - yeah it has to go back
and rooks e7 yeah let's know what if
white gets here this is this is game
over I guess now that's no good
just just give this up yeah yeah yeah
also have this now yeah rookie three
nights you for work trapped Bishop c6 it
was an unsuccessful movie out probably
Bishop statistics at the end it also
says mistake okay I mean you have simply
decided to play a six rooks is seven a
seven and and promote this pawn it's
going to be difficult to prevent any way
it's gifting y2 Tempe probably didn't
help and she like resigned hmm double
hot game but probably what worked
wonders here was kramnik strategy of
playing an offbeat opening that just
basically yeah get them get the born
into the game here like in tennis yeah
you just want to serve and see that you
have a yeah you have a game going ever
get the ball over the net and then see
what happens
and grease will burn time and then some
inaccuracies crept in at the end of the
at the end of the pier closer to the
time control probably like isn't in such
terrible shape and the odd moment I mean
the computer evaluations suggest that
but like he em if you see here like the
best move was age five according to the
computer these are not the most natural
moves ever yeah so they can find of
course the best moves oftentimes moves
that the engine gives but the computer
takes some just seven seconds to to come
up with them but if you are in time
trouble difficult
so yeah I think I'm rather readily clear
victory for chrome decay he was never
verse and I think his overall strategy
worked quite well okay we have kayaking
Mahmoud yarrow so here I saw the opening
and I was quite surprised about about
the whole opening play they played this
line the g6 defense to the to the whim
that is sometimes called smooth Slavs
variation and this is a line that I
always I always felt is I always felt no
Syria I always felt that this is an
interesting line here black wants to go
Bishop g7 to cover oops
wow that was wrong Bishop g7 to cover
the pawn and often later and go for some
play on the Kings side with f5 a lot
later of course and it's interesting to
see that Mohammad yafa is trying this
line because he has played this
variation quite a lot in the past and
this is a related line for example if
you play like this black can play let
the right move order I think it's a
right move where black goes g6 here and
this is a way that that's quite
comparable let's say this idea I'm very
surprised that c3 c3 was played and now
a6 and what kayaking is doing now I
think is quite surprising I would
absolutely suspect and expect to play
Bishop a4 and he took on c6 and play d4
I don't understand that really well at
this point what the point is here I mean
my understanding of the central
structure is that this kind of
transformation can
be ok for black I always thought this
must be good for black black has the two
bishops and he can pressurize the center
with easy moves I mean that does not put
any pressure on black I thought but
maybe I'm wrong
so Bishop g4 was played immediately
putting some pressure on the center
Queen b3 ok looking at this one
yeah very concrete stuff interesting so
Mohammed Yara was willing to give up b7
and winning deform in exchange so how
does that work out if he if kurakin
would have taken this what does black do
actually 97 problem never light itself
can you get that back for sure
Oh bishop is free he was played 97 93
and black took on d4 okay just grab it
and now he just traded on d4 yeah long
castles as the engine suggested here
looks a lot more natural
so what is the entrance line c5 yeah
that has to be played anyway and it's
now 92 okay
yeah that low castles looks more natural
but why probably doesn't have anything
when the the entrance line looks fairly
logical and this is probably equal six
months it's probably roughly equal and
just looks a bit odd yeah to to simply
take there and take on b7
one issue here is I mean simply if if
you imagine in this I don't know how the
game actually ends you know I mean I
know that that black wins but I don't
know how exactly what is the problem
here potentially he said and see that
white castle's short this is not really
an helpful extra pawn I mean it helps a
little bit in shielding the Kingman it's
not something you can do much with and
if stuff just gets traded down you're
not ever going to do much with your pawn
so look b8 and castles now that was no
good
so my white rather castled
and rook p227 Quincy three King G - Wow
so black is winning this that said stuff
so kayaking didn't put up his his
defensive magic he in this game and this
is a typical kind of position that he
would not lose typically lots of
typically when he is pretty good at
playing bad positions and here he did
not manage to hold it now I don't think
it's terrible for wider just annoying to
play 95 instead of rook a be 8 yeah we
can begin to contest 95 Wow
Wow okay I mean I guess the politics are
you going rupee a trust
even cream III could be the idea yeah
yeah 23 years the shanks and rookie
haters and as an idea like here here
that could work
I just wonder I mean white after 95 then
the white does not have to take it I
mean with the porn I mean you can also
take it with this
I mean like here here white is probably
okay
maybe maybe so in the game what did
happened in the game some look see 281
look true so this position okay Wow
some white sleuthing this I mean that's
not fun to play
that's definitely definitely the case
but if I'm media of wins those kind of
positions he has a good shot of
qualifying so I wonder I saw that this
was on the board but they got to a queen
ending yeah
that's an awkward career ending to play
it really is awkward they probably took
ages right how many moves did that take
71 oh my god
Queen endings are the worst yeah they
take forever Queen g5 chick well okay
the idea that black hands is very simple
and you need to just push the pawn
without getting into a perpetual this is
mostly a calculation job the Queen only
five makes a good impression it's just a
nicely centralized piece it prevents
every check on that diagonal and you're
ready to push that makes a lot of sense
so H Form B form and the Queen went here
yeah this is now that's a really good
setup that he found and kayaking
yeah Wendy five I just wanted to suggest
that he has to do something like that
just to try to trade yeah black takes
here Y takes on before so that here
would be nothing for white you can
easily defend the pawns look a little
bit a little bit weird but it's a yeah
it's nothing that black can do much
against so instead b3 was played and now
what about e6 in this position you play
King G to where what happens after a six
can you just push
of course you have thanks em it's it's
been a long day yeah this is much
stronger sorry that just gives away upon
yeah so II six doesn't work probably
this is why I'm King g2 was played
going to see for ya mean black can
probably always keep this under control
and keep this as well but I'm not quite
seeing how he makes any headway maybe
six for the check and black frees up
this okay
is that really lost for white I mean
that could Sylvia draw
sorry there's either whoopers I cannot
really follow your train of thought
it's a bit difficult for f76 I seem
I see what you mean that all that looks
that looks very difficult for to hold at
this first glance I would say it looks
difficult to hold when you're King
position is it's so bad with one yep the
difficult so how did that how did that
turn out he went f4 I mean that's true
we have what what tried go says black
were crying it out and it's not so much
important if that is a win or draw in
the theoretical sense in an analytical
sense but it's just I was just asking
with myself if that is really it really
is a win I mean we we see the analogy of
the engine and it gives 0.8 only here
attend it gets it gets into lower lower
territory kingi to Pistons was king age
three okay
so black managed to play g5 aha
okay ng5 aha can you get me five okay
that looks very critical now now this
has to happen
and he'll be too was stronger supposedly
but and this makes a lot of sense check
and now this one I know King f1 was
better really
this is something that that the computer
should evaluate just pretty much
perfectly if you give it enough time
it does make no sense
and the engine doesn't give much yeah
and reasonable depth
I just wonder what is the ask that -
force is coming from that's why that's
weird
yeah here b2 was completely winning okay
now the king is quite safe now all of a
sudden you and you're just threatening
to move the Queen and promote yeah that
makes a lot of sense yes still they are
probably in in a time trouble here again
so that's understandable someone and
around here that still it wrong probably
him King g3 if why would he do that
therefore was stronger okay huh why
would he give it away I mean I
understand that he saw that it is it was
it was some hangings or f4
it's really weird you know because I
mean here I would assume that black
would have to put the Queen somewhere
here and then play b2 to win and then
you have the checks on the dark squares
for probably a perpetual I didn't feel
like he needed to give it away it's a
very good strange I don't know how would
play this more accurately I'm terrible
at those kind of situations but I'm just
wondering it doesn't it doesn't make
much sense to me why it would give it up
I mean maybe he was thinking that the
pawn is not so relevant and potentially
there could be a check Here I am
I know the king is just coming up and
him somehow resigns him with with the
move plate but unusual huh so probably
kayaking did not need to lose this
ending up tough now itself if he is not
holding this his main strength didn't
didn't come to light let's say yeah yeah
black black played so this okay I mean
when he's great at saving bad positions
and that is his main his main strength
and he couldn't couldn't save that one
yeah there was a super important game I
think right right in the first round
some things we know we are very likely
kayaking will have trouble to qualify
very likely we're losing with white is
bad and he's not the guy wins like five
or six games so that won't happen if he
gets two plus two or plus three that is
probably the kind of score I can manage
and starting with the loss with white
Mahmud Yara is the kind of player you
could say anything can happen in the
tournament and him starting with the
witness of course fantastic for him yeah
krome nick is certainly happy with the
win and also Caruana Caruana didn't have
super great last year so also not that
not a gradient so all the winners are
certainly happy how my voice is
completely failing me all the winners
are certainly happy for obvious reasons
but it is um really am really important
to note that in such a in such an event
it's fourteen rounds but the players are
so close to one another in the last
three tournaments at
and the +3 score was enough to to win
and to qualify I think it was +3 so any
win is super important for us of course
for Aronian nothing is lost or for
digging is just a draw and we have
Aronian mahmud yarrow of tomorrow that's
very very cool pairing I guess from
Adyar off with white yeah yeah I think
yeah cotton is certainly watching the
tournament of what what else he will
certainly have a look at the games but I
[Music]
mean he is probably right with the
assumption that whoever qualifies is the
underdog and it's mostly about him doing
what he does best to win the match
there's nobody know one of those
contenders is a natural candidate to
become the next world champion nobody
there's nobody in the industry is
younger than him significantly younger
and and quite obviously nobody is
stronger so it might still happen that
we will get a more interesting match
with some of those potential qualifiers
will be yeah will be interesting to see
how it turns out a good round tomorrow
I'm looking forward to to do that
actually if you are here in my area in
the body beat in Germany I'm doing live
commentary tomorrow in the Chess Club of
garrison creation boooo hustle and they
have a they have a Bremen and everything
and I will be there to to do live
commentary on the second round it's it's
free it's not they don't have a fee or
anything and you're happy to to come to
gasification to watch that
do I think if karlie worship in 2020 and
that's just that's just two years from
now right well that's likely he just
needs to win this match so yeah it's not
not more its I mean here I think he
would definitely have the potential to
to hold the title for not longer I just
wonder I just wonder how long is
interested in doing that this is more
more interesting question I don't know
as the address of off together
just she'll just Chess Club in girls
occasion boo herself yeah I can't put it
in deaf this is where I'm going to do
the commentary tomorrow starting at yeah
it depends at 3:00 or 4:00 I hope to be
there on time I have a league game
tomorrow in fact and no hustle is the
it's the part of the town
it's like Brooklyn belongs to New York
or something like that
knowing probably people from Brooklyn
would argue I don't know yeah so okay
yeah thanks for watching this little
walkthrough of the games it was um it
was a relatively brief one you can dig a
lot deeper but I hope you in enjoyed the
overview of the games thanks a lot for
watching I try to do the same tomorrow
evening but it's a little bit unsure how
this turns out thanks a lot bye bye